bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
[Music]
all right guys bang bang i have senator
lumbus here with us thank you so much
for doing this man
my pleasure anthony it's great to be
with you today
for sure for those that don't know you
maybe let's just start with your
background
um before you became a senator uh kind
of where did you grow up and what did
you do
well i'm a ranch girl from wyoming i was
born
near cheyenne and ranch there to this
day with my brother and my sister
i also have a farm over on the western
side of the state
we have hay and cattle and then in the
fall we take in a lot of
horses that are coming in off the pack
strings that are on the bridger teton
national forest in the summer
so my background is primarily ranching
but
i also have a law degree i practice law
for nine years and
and i've spent a lot of time in and out
of politics
i was in our state legislature worked
for our governor in wyoming was state
treasurer
in the u.s house and now i'm in the u.s
senate
doing a fantastic job um you've got a
passion for
bitcoin where did that come from when
did you first come across bitcoin and
where does that passion really kind of
come from i was state treasurer in
wyoming during the first part of the
21st century so i was always looking for
a store of value we have in wyoming
permanent funds
that are based on extracting minerals
and oil and gas from the ground
we take a severance tax it's called from
minerals
and invested in a permanent fund and the
concept
of that permanent mineral trust fund is
that when the minerals are gone
we will still have revenue left over
because
we invested the proceeds and continue to
invest them in a diversified
asset allocation so while we're taking
something valuable from the ground and
converting it to cash
i wanted to convert the cash into things
that produced income for the short term
but also produce long term value just
like those minerals did when they were
in the ground
so i was always looking for things that
had were a good store
of value the more i learned about
bitcoin
uh the more the uh nomenclature
of bitcoin reminded me of our permanent
mineral trust fund
uh bitcoin is essentially mined uh there
will only be 21 million bitcoin
mind uh and because it is a finite
resource
uh i see it as a very good store of
value
so i bought a few bitcoin uh in
2013 and 2014 and
have continued to pay attention to it
ever since
and of course we've seen it of course be
volatile going up and down
but i still think it is an excellent
store of value
and that it should be part of every
individual
person's investment portfolio
now if you look at your average
blue-collar worker the guy or gal that's
out there
land bricks are building the apartment
across the street from these
senate office buildings
the if they invest just in the u.s
dollar
the dollar is designed uh to be worth
less every year
and so if they're saving now let's say
they're in their 20s or 30s now
when they get my age that money that
they have worked so
hard all their lives to save it's it if
it's denominated in us dollars
is not going to buy as much as it does
now so trying to help people
find things that will capture the value
capture the value of their hard work now
and make it available to them in the
future when they're my age when people
start to retire
um that's something that uh that makes
me excited about being back in the u.s
senate
uh i was always a fiscal hawk when i was
here before
and um i am watching us rack up debt
uh to the tune of now 27 trillion we're
talking about another 2 trillion here
with the new administration the money
is going to buy less and less over time
so looking at things that everyday
americans
the person who works at walmart uh the
rancher
across the fence for me um though those
people
the teachers uh the firefighters the
capitol policemen around here who
did such a good job here uh this month
um
i want to help them find things that
will store
value so when they get my age and they
start retiring
it's actually worth something yeah
do you think that we're headed towards a
situation where eventually every
state whether it's the permanent fund in
wyoming or other funds that they have
we'll have to look at this as well
i know that we've got kind of
individuals we've got some financial
institutions now
a couple of corporations but we haven't
seen lots of movement either at the
state local or federal level in
government
do you think that'll change over time or
do you think it's more so this asset
will be something for individuals and
corporations but not necessarily
government entities
i hope it will be for all of the above
as part of a fully diversified asset
allocation
so uh for example if you
are um a postal worker
i believe that the postal workers
retirement funds
should be uh have the opportunity to
invest in bitcoin
uh not bitcoin exclusively but bitcoin
has a wide var variety an array of
assets
i think that should be true of permanent
mineral trust funds like wyoming has new
mexico has
alaska has and and other government
funds
uh that are trying to find a slice of
their investments to store
value now if you want assets that are
throwing off
income you know maybe you want to go to
the
um s p 500 some spiders
uh some large cap growth uh strategies
but if you
if you want to store value for the long
term sort of is uh to protect yourself
from inflation
uh that's where i think that bitcoin
plays
an important role now and someday its
role may expand
but uh for this day and age i really see
it as a great store of value
for individuals for corporations and for
government
yeah that's great um about a year and a
half ago i went and i met with
a number of offices uh in the house and
at the time i think my takeaway really
was just there hadn't been a lot of
education
of uh elected officials when it came to
bitcoin
um the pros and the cons the technology
kind of the impact that something like
this could have
across society and kind of the american
economy
uh with you kind of uh sitting now
within a elected role how do you think
about educating your colleagues and and
kind of spending time talking to them
and getting them up to speed
without just being you know oh she's the
one who's always kind of uh talking
about bitcoin and therefore they kind of
tune you out like
how do you just think about the
education that you can do now that
you're actually in the room as a
colleague rather than someone on the
outside
well that's a great question anthony and
i i want to reach out
to the people who are listening to your
podcast to help with this
we're forming a financial innovations
caucus
in the senate we hope to use it
as a springboard uh to educate um
members of the u.s senate and their
staff
about uh bitcoin specifically but about
other
uh opportunities for cryptocurrencies
and uh
uh financial innovation and blockchain
uses of blockchain um and so
um i i'm interested in knowing how
the people who are listening to your
podcast
uh would expose members of the us senate
to that kind of
information what is pithy what works
what worked with them what resonates
with your
listeners uh that i can use
uh to help uh educate and inform
uh the people that i work with about
financial innovation so to the extent
that anybody's interested
i'm at um at scn lummus
senator limits maybe let's talk a little
bit about kind of the sentiment among
your colleagues
uh when it comes to bitcoin uh and or
central bank digital currencies right
there's a lot of talk about bitcoin
uh usually tied to kind of price and i
think sentiment falls price a little bit
but there's also a lot of talk about
central bank digital currencies um
and even potentially digitizing the
dollar how have you seen the sentiment
and kind of what are people
talking about uh within congress in the
senate uh
when it comes to these two types of kind
of financial innovations
well i think one of the first things
that we're going to be working on
is fighting a narrative about digital
assets and crypto being used for money
laundering
uh because that is uh you know game
stopper
right from the beginning uh so now what
we know is according to
chain analysis um cryptocurrency related
crime
is smaller than criminal activity with
cash
uh and crypto regulations need to
leave room for innovation so among the
things we're going to want to do
while we're uh informing people is to
make sure that we have the opportunity
to innovate and that
includes uh in the area of things like
stable coin
for example um facebook i think has
stable coin
in a pilot in switzerland or something
and the federal reserve is looking to
create its own digital currency
so we'll want to be visiting with the
federal reserve
about what their plans are how they want
to roll it out what we can do to help
them innovate and
the the innovation in this area could
help companies through faster
transactions
than typical wire transfers for example
it takes a long time
to clear a wire transfer
when you're sending money
internationally and so we want to
have the opportunity to use
advanced financial technologies to make
those kinds of opportunities more
available
so commerce can be more robust than it
is today
i visited with janet yellen the new
treasury secretary on the phone the
other day uh before her
confirmation hearing and she um
this is an area where i think that she
has an
open mind she's she has some of the same
concerns that most do in financial
technology there
are concerned about uh criminal or
nefarious use of
of uh cryptocurrency so it's going to
take a lot of work
uh to get to where we can um
uh have an open dialogue that is uh free
from the clutter
of seeing this knee-jerk reaction to the
concern that
that uh all crypto is subject to uh
criminal activity
to a very large degree now there are
some areas where
we've been working with we were working
prior to
the transition to the biden
administration
with secretary mnuchin
about the bank secrecy act and about the
digital asset rule
and i was happy that they were
willing to extend the comment period for
that
and now that the biden administration uh
is in place uh rule making has been
frozen indefinitely so that should give
us more time
uh to comment and help them understand
uh how to make it more consistent
with existing law uh how to make sure
that we're not talking about knowing
your customers customer
uh and pushing them too far out on the
spectrum to
uh to make it reasonable
this is a complex rule i don't even
understand at all
that's why i have great advisors around
me and
i'm looking forward to working with
treasury and with state and federal
financial regulators and with industry
to ensure the rules uh recognize
the critical role of innovation
including digital assets and
uh america's financial future is going
to be very much tied to this
we're seeing china get way ahead of us
in this area
and lots of other areas anthony that
that we need to
make sure that we can dominate
and be effective in the way that we
innovate but
at the same time uh guard against
uh financial innovation uh being used by
the chinese communist party so
uh i think it's really important uh that
the united states uh
not take too long on the education piece
that we get it we learn it and then we
move forward
uh because uh this is an area where
um some of our uh competing countries
around the world in
in the financial arena are going to
uh um struggle
so i i think what's really interesting
about what you're talking about here is
like one
uh i think most people who don't
understand this oh cryptocurrencies that
has this
um kind of uh you know place
psychologically in people's minds
that uh nefarious people use it right as
we know with
other technologies whether it was
beepers cell phones internet etc
uh people who are doing bad things or
nefarious things always adopt these
technologies first that doesn't make the
technology bad that just means that we
should tell the bad people not to do bad
things with it
so i think you're right there um the
other thing that seems to be coming up
more and more and you alluded to this a
little
bit is um there's this balance between
uh global competition right if all of a
sudden
uh another country was to adopt some of
these financial innovations and
able to uh harness them in a way that
would give them a significant advantage
on that global stage
uh that wouldn't be great for the united
states uh but the balance
to that or kind of the counter uh is
that oh well the united states may see
some of these technologies as a threat
to
themselves and therefore there are
people calling for banning
uh whether it's cryptocurrencies or
other technologies it sounds like you're
kind of in the camp of look
if the technology is going to be out
there we need to be embracing it rather
than fighting it
you know first is that kind of an
accurate depiction of your position
and two just how do you think about that
geopolitical landscape and kind of how
it's playing out
uh given many of these other countries
are uh making a big push to adopt some
of these technologies
now that is an accurate depiction
of my position i'm i want to be very
robust in this area i want the united
states to be a leader
uh in my home state of wyoming
we have the most innovative laws in the
country
on uh blockchain and
cryptocurrency technology we even put in
place
a chancery court through which
litigation involving the new laws
uh could be handled and um i
i think that just like delaware did in
the case of
uh corporate formations uh
there's a a court that is uh ver
that has great expertise uh and that is
readily available and we wanted to make
that the case in wyoming too
so we could be the innovators in uh
american law
uh at the uh at the state level
uh that we be the innovators and and
let's
let the incubators of good ideas go
ahead and incubate those good ideas and
states are among those
in government in the private sector it
tends to be
actual business incubators and
and and business startups and formations
in government it tends to be the states
uh so we wanted to make sure that
wyoming was a leader in that regard
and we want to continue to be a leader
in that regard
so part of the reason that i got into
this is because i was state treasurer
part of the reason i got into this is
because
my son-in-law and his friends are are
very knowledgeable
uh about bitcoin uh and then the final
reason was watching
wyoming become a great innovator at the
state level
uh in uh in bitcoin law
the nation can be that uh we're
we're a little bit behind right now uh
behind other countries
uh but we need to be part of that you
know
anthony i did a little bit of consulting
for the world bank on sovereign wealth
funds
after i was state treasurer and we have
seen
other countries create sovereign wealth
funds like vietnam they have a fabulous
textile industry
uh countries that you that would
surprise you uh
have savings accounts or sovereign
wealth funds uh those would be
great uh places
uh to capture and innovate in the area
of
financial technology the abu dhabi
investment authority
norgas bank in norway norway has a
tremendous offshore oil and gas resource
that they invest
for their the benefit of norwegians
they would be a logical country to
innovate in this
area so uh some very unlikely
uh bedfellows uh
may be able to innovate in this area all
for the good
uh of uh the people that they're
that they serve yeah it's fantastic uh
you mentioned earlier
uh kind of every institution having uh
exposure
not necessarily converting all of their
portfolio or their
uh currency to bitcoin but having it as
a piece
um one of the institutions that i think
people are very interested in
uh is central banks right it looks like
already
obviously the individuals the
corporations the financial institutions
are starting to get exposure but we
haven't really seen
anywhere in the world a central bank
make that decision
maybe not so much like which one do you
think is first in a timeline but more so
what do you think is the actual steps to
doing that right is that something where
um that decision let's say in the united
states would get made by
um the uh chairman of the federal
reserve and the treasury secretary do
you think that's
more of a democratic process just what's
the path to that happening
uh here in the united states well that's
a great question and we want to meet
with
the federal reserve about that
specifically because we do think
that the federal reserve uh will want to
innovate in this area
and we want to work with them hand in
hand on that innovation
i also want congress to be uh the driver
of that innovation uh so we are
uh the actual policy maker and
they are the actual implementer
yeah that's fantastic what can people do
at home to help you i feel like you
uh are educated you're very passionate
about bitcoin
um you have this very unique um
but important view of financial
innovation
and the role that the united states and
the united states government can play on
a global stage in terms of embracing
this
uh and continuing to remain kind of that
lighthouse on the hill
uh for the rest of the world is there
something that people at home can do
to either one make your job easier uh or
two to kind of help further your mission
as you kind of continue to uh
to operate inside the senate with uh
with this viewpoint
absolutely there are a lot of people
around this country
who know more about the nuts and bolts
of blockchain and
bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies than
i know
i have a rudimentary understanding of it
and i'm trying
to use that rudimentary understanding
uh to educate people who
even don't have that much of an
understanding so part of it is
communications
and i can use i've already mentioned
that that would be helpful
the other thing is um
in in the case of people who are have
very sophisticated expertise on this
we would love to have them contact our
office
and and give us ideas and finally
for people who want to see
this kind of innovation move forward
contact your u.s senator
and say hey we understand that there's a
new
uh financial innovations caucus in the
u.s
senate we encourage you to join it we
want it to be bipartisan
the one of the fun things for me about
this topic
is it's it's bipartisan it
it does it crosses uh all kinds of party
lines
uh and so we need to have the
involvement
of democrats republicans independents
libertarians
uh and everything in between uh so
we can innovate in this area there's
the way we have the gridlock in
washington is so intense right now
that if you can find any little crack to
break through the gridlock
uh we should take advantage of it and
that's if we can innovate in one area
like this that is not partisan it
doesn't wear
a partisan hat a democrat had a
republican hat
and if we can innovate in an area like
this it might help
us uh break the dam
and innovate in other areas too and in
in this day and age in washington find
anything that you can innovate on
uh is exciting because we're
so set in the concrete that we can't
even lift our feet anymore around here
but this is an area where that's not
true so that's another reason that i'm
excited about
being new to the senate uh but having
old friends that i serve within the u.s
house
in the senate uh we can talk about a
topic that crosses party lines and
and uh it it it gives this a chance to
innovate
and that's really exciting to me and i i
think other people will
embrace the idea that wow here's an
avenue
that we can just be americans we don't
have to be democrats or republicans we
can just be americans
and use the ingenuity and innovation
that america was always known for
and was the world leader in we can use
that in this area
so yet another reason that i'm really
excited about financial innovation
yeah you're just doing a fantastic job
so uh from everyone else
thank you i think that um as you
continue to kind of spread the
this message and frankly it's just a
refreshing perspective
on on the importance of not only your
job but also
your colleagues and so i think that the
more folks we can get to uh to have your
perspective the better off we'll be
uh regardless of people's political
views so uh so i really appreciate that
um we're gonna send people to uh your
twitter account which is at
sen loomis um is there
anywhere else that you would like for us
to send people
is there anywhere else we'd like we we
here again i have to turn to my
colleagues our website
islamist.senate.gov
okay our website is lummus.senate.gov
all right we will uh we'll send a bunch
of people over there hopefully we'll
break your website because there's so
much traffic of everyone trying to learn
about everything that you're doing
uh senator listen thank you so much for
your time today um and you know as i
mentioned
i think that you're doing a great job so
i appreciate all the hard work and
we'll have to do it again in the future
well it's going to be a heavy lift
anthony so i need you and all of the
people that follow you to help out but
thank you kindly and i look forward to
visiting with you again as well